hello would welcome to this video
playing kind of myself what is this
reading that's ridiculous in 2600 nickel
diner eating I ever have a crap score
against this person check minus five but
this is an old language reading he never
was that high right he had to 688 at one
point my god okay really not you don't
see this all that often for an IM 2600
in the pool here okay Bishop c4 normally
it's not that dangerous ya can even do
this
he takes that I can go look a five at
the end activating the rook checking you
five submission a success is also
possible that at one moment ok justice
yeah where'd you go I would like to go
to a B form if possible for see 596 but
it's an unstable square unstable square
so I go back to seven he has efore of
course ok rather look is kind of funky
on a six of course well maybe this is
very various dangerous for me and I also
could've played like g6 these kind of
things ok that's the possibility of it
was just prevent my nightie form
okay let's see if i'm annoying here
spit strange but at least I was somewhat
quick and maybe just look to the one
it's not fun really isn't create a jay i
would still play up to three I guess
yeah I kind of have to doesn't look nice
but cannot defend like the deep on or
all the time and it won't work so it
tries for f5 tricks
so we're up the eight a little bit on
the passive side don't like it so much
but it's difficult difficult to avoid
really
I wonder if I can play yeah anyway kunle
six was my first side yard this this one
also wasn't totally clear to me yeah
with my back rank my back rank Queenie
three maybe four the chick made and
queen age 6
maybe I could have taken in quincy for
know then you go slower than leather
don't have worked
hmm
hmm I don't know
time warning yeah I know I know I know I
know but am I saying this I don't quite
see it
probably goes back I can one I don't
know I don't know Queenie one probably
yeah but Queenie aid from the king of
six my basic idea is Queenie a deaf 6
king of seven and pick it up which is
kind of funny if it would work I have to
go here right ok this is the trick hmm
check back with a night okay that's
funny that's funny okay black resigned
yeah if he always had pressure i mean i
think i basically got out of it but it
was still annoying very annoying to play
I don't think that I should still lose
this position to be honest but it's
extremely extremely annoying to play so
this this queenie queenie for losses due
to 23 yeah i was already saying that
during the rod brewing the actual
recording that this wins but it didn't
see it Quincy six I have to play it
seems he says I'm a fish yes I have no
idea can hear some of the engine cesses
hair these awards but it looks bad yeah
I had a pretty bad position out of the
opening
yeah this is princess probably wrong
yeah this is also confirmed by the
engineer gets too much pressure on the
deep on now I was surprised that he
actually took but it is just a good good
decision I'm just very weak on that deep
porn yeah yeah well played by water can
you do I probably have to play it
differently in the opening this at least
a c5 was I was wrong yeah the engine
just wants to cancel yeah maybe Bishop
a6 isn't good I mean it's possible the
engine wants to play stuff like that if
he grabs now I always have this this is
really quite nice it activates that
position enormously something like this
could be interesting the engine gives us
as equal I don't know I'm not sure about
this sometimes the computers are
nowadays very much focused on best
possible activity and today sometimes
don't evaluate iria all that high now
this was good for white very good friend
ok guys thanks for watching